let's talk about this first story we got
this from blick.ch
due to compulsory vaccination from
february austria is looking for people
to control those who refuse to be
vaccinated anyone who does not want to
be vaccinated in austria from february
2022 must expect a fine employees should
ensure the fines are paid that is why uh
that is why we are now looking for
inspectors
i must stress we used google translate
so some of these words may not get the
full and correct meaning across but uh
uh my understanding is look at this the
vaccination inspectors receive a wage of
at least 2 744 euros
or about 28 80 francs
they say uh lens now wants to engage
people who are supposed to control
vaccine vaccination refusals as reported
today they should check whether those
who do not get vaccinated are really
paying for it translation error because
whoever does not get vaccinated will be
asked to pay up to 3600 euro the
equivalent of a good
3740 francs
well history repeats itself i suppose
some people call them inspectors i think
hunters is is a better uh more
appropriate term here statist hunters
going after you know individuals who
believe in bodily autonomy now this is
again according to a lot of local news
reports coming out of austria they're
talking about how they're going to be
paying people nearly 40 000 a year to do
this job how the fines could range a
couple thousand dollars of course a
couple thousand euros but uh
this again goes along with the decree
that they're going to be pushing forward
in february that pretty much outlaws
individuals
who are not vaccinated which is
absolutely crazy germany has talked
about imposing similar measures
themselves their health minister
recently said that they want to
implement mandatory vaccinations on
everyone austria's doing it how this
policy will be implemented it's going to
be nasty it's going to be disgusting
because people are going to be called up
people are going to be investigated
people are going to be spied on tracked
traced and databased and said hey did
you take the shot and they're going to
have to say no and then the government's
going to come with jack boot thugs and
say you're going to give us money or
you're going to go to jail it's going to
happen which is crazy but regardless of
how the policy actually gets activated
what are the people going to do the
people are still unvaccinated in austria
are they going to acquiesce by the by in
large numbers or are they going to fight
back what do you think's going to happen
over there i think what would you do
i'm i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to be forced to do anything i'm
not going to be forced to say something
i don't want to say or do something i
want to do
period yeah like that's just my
personality i agree yeah so
the local reports that we're also
hearing about is that they will be
working with employers and saying that
they will be denying them paychecks or
taking their paychecks away from them um
and pressuring them to do this uh that
way so uh i mean obviously i wouldn't
what if they can't get the vaccine you
know
what if they can't get it for medical or
religious reasons um
if you've received like let's say you're
an older person you've received
monoclonal antibodies you can't get it
for 90 days so like what do they do it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter which
reason is yeah so so here here's what
i'll add to this right what we saw last
year is europe started doing these
lockdowns then the us started picking
them up
we started seeing europe locking down
again now we've got all these major
cities in the u.s doing it boston is
doing it chicago's announcing it and i'm
i'm actually headed back to chicago i'm
like oh man i don't even know if i want
to go oh boy yeah because they have mask
mandates and now they're saying they
want a vaccine many for all restaurants
and i'm like i'm supposed to go there
for the holidays
why would i why would i want to go give
money to a place like that or be
involved in a place like that out in
west virginia none of that people walk
around doing whatever they want not not
only do you not have to wear a mask you
can carry a gun oh yeah illinois is the
opposite of that you go to jail and
you'll get fined and uh it's very so
they're saying now i think
they're going to implement a vaccine
mandate for indoor dining and like some
restaurant association in chicago is
saying wait until after the holidays
because we want to make money so here's
what i think
we're seeing this in austria we're
seeing it in germany we're seeing it
escalate and they're ahead of us i think
it's very likely we will get to this
point in the united states very soon
well one thing that i've been kind of
making the point about is that a lot of
these restrictions a lot of these
mandates all kind of come in steps and
we're seeing the steps followed almost
identically but under different names
all around the world so obviously
austria uh
kind of is leading the pack here but
what what is happening in austria is
going to be happening with the rest of
the world we saw australia kind of leave
the world with their insanity the other
other places are going to be following
suit with very similar policies as well
we just saw boston implement their quote
be together initiative which is
absolutely draconian orwellian and
insane it's like calling you know the
patriot act patriotic but it absolutely
wasn't it was the exact opposite of that
doesn't it just feel good to be a a a a
face in the crowd of people with
pitchforks and torches mindlessly
marching along and demanding everyone
else capitulate and and you know march
alongside the state doesn't it just feel
good right come on everyone wants to do
that you're basically saying suffer as i
suffer yeah yeah join the club if i have
to deal with this so do you if i have to
take a risk
you do as well which is absolutely crazy
that's exactly right absolutely insane
and and again their their quote be
together initiative is literally
requiring vaccine passports for indoor
activities which is predominantly going
to be discriminating against black
people in this country
i'm with shep smith i don't care i don't
want to talk about it anymore
that what was that what was that he said
he said maybe i'm just better getting
off omicron
for biden's sake we'll call it omnicron
that
i was told this when i was in um
uh was it catalonia in in like barcelona
they said that they have the the catalan
lisp
where like in spanish instead of saying
cerveza they say fedora bartholomew
barcelona and they said so it was funny
because i was in spain
there was a guy you know i'm talking to
these guys and i said um you know i've
never been to barcelona and he goes
barcelona and i went oh it's barthelon
and he was yes and then another guy was
like no no it's barcelona and i was like
which one is it well apparently
apparently here's the legend there was a
king or something who had a lisp so
everyone wanted to be high status so
they started speaking with a lisp
because it was you know
prestigious so that's why we call it
omnicron because we you know because
biden is the is the is the is the
epitome of prestige yes
much easier to say anyway
smith went off he just said it he's
literally thinking that it might just be
better off for him he's triple faxed he
said to just get omnicron he was like
just give it to me so i can move on with
my life i don't want to see it reported
of coming from a you know corporate
press broadcaster he doesn't want to see
it reported he's just he's he's at his
wit's end just like jim cramer he had a
similar rant anti-vaxxers yeah that's
the only explanation yeah of course yeah
well a lot of people are having fatigue
just hearing about this non-stop and
non-stop and that's because the
government has been kind of beating this
thing over the head exploiting it to the
fullest extent trying to squeeze the
limit to the last drop and people are
like we get it we got it and again how
much sensationalistic fear-mongering
nonsense can you throw at them before
they're like we don't care they don't
give a damn that's so funny so annie
vaxxer is because it reminds me of this
old uh saying in the theater if you
scratch an actor you you'll see an
actress you scratch if you scratch a
boxer you'll see an antivirus what does
that mean what does that mean it's
basically just like if you bring any
kind of uh like you know actors are
supposedly very sensitive oh you think
of somebody like ian very sensitive guy
you scratch them they'll turn into an
actress so if you if you scratch or
confuse or harm a vaxxer somebody that's
triple vaxxed and they think they think
they're really safe then you're going to
see somebody you're going to see the
anti-vaxxer just explode out i'm just
saying this i'm saying
you know if the vaccine works
and they all say it does
then these people are lying and they get
the vaccine oh that's what i'm saying
like
and and it's funny too because i think
we mentioned this yesterday how many how
many times did viral videos go around
where they're like look nancy pelosi is
not really getting vaccinated or
whatever yeah everybody was accusing
these people of not really getting the
vaccine and many of these people were
saying they weren't going to get it on
twitter because they were like trump's
vaccine i won't do it now all of a
sudden they're getting sick i'm like
just call them anti-vexers period
because they clearly lied about getting
the maxi now i don't know if they
actually did or not i know efficacy
wayne's supposed to get boosters and all
that stuff but i got no problem just
saying these people are are you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna operate under the
assumption that they just lied about
getting vaccinated well well the other
explanation to this is that there's a
conspiracy and
yeah there's that i don't think they
should uh i think i think you know what
i think i think there's like a million
micro conspiracies you know what i mean
yeah i i think you know the the we're
going to find out the truth in a couple
years from now and i think we're going
to be shocked about what really was
going on today oh that this is how it
always happens with history i think how
how long did they say the gulf of tonkin
was a conspiracy theory the gulf of
tonkin incident the conspiracy theory
being that that america basically staged
the attack so we could you know enter
vietnam and i remember hearing about how
it was a conspiracy theory up until even
like only a few years ago and they were
like oh yeah actually the us did stage
that so there's there's tons of stuff
throughout history
that is purposely obfuscated and then
later on when you find out what really
happened you're like wow
so how much longer until we actually get
the unredacted documents from the
assassination you know well the fda is
waiting for 75 years to release the
clinical studies about the pfizer
vaccine i heard they walked it back to
55 years because they're feeling more
confident in their product either way
they have the data and you know they say
they need you know decades to procure it
even though it's already procured and
ready to go but uh you know for our big
our well-being and understanding they
don't need any liability and they don't
need to present it until 55 years from
now which is i bet a lot of ufo stories
was just us military drone research
how hard would it be for the military to
create a quadcopter you know in the 70s
or 80s they could probably do it and
that explains why people were saying
they saw discs zipping back and forth
and moving really crazy because if you
ever watched like pro high powered
drones these things go nuts the way they
can move so rapidly and the german
military during world war ii was also
working on saucer like flying
devices as well so there's even photos
of some that look eerily similar to what
some people call of course ufos so
there's a lot of probabilities there's a
lot of things that of course we don't
know about because the government is
being extremely secretive they're hiding
a lot of data they're hiding a lot of
important information from the general
public as they're telling you trust us
give us give us your freedom give us
your economic opportunities give us your
life but we're not going to show you
anything on your end and that's
disgusting you know be really funny
there are two different scenarios that i
find would be really funny one is that
everything the government says is
completely true
like
it really was a weird-shaped cloud that
descended you know hovered spun in a
circle and then
darted off it really was a cloud believe
us why would you believe this or it's
just like
it's so far beyond what anyone actually
thinks it is and what's really happening
in the government and like with aliens
is just it's like not aliens it's just
something completely ridiculous that no
one would ever
like theorize about but i actually i
actually think like the funniest
scenario is the government's telling the
truth because that implies honesty among
the government and a lack of any like
intent for like military technology to
be you know and that they're competent
that's another idea yeah that scenario
got the biggest laugh in the room yeah
they're actually telling the truth
they're like so absurd to consider yeah
the ufo everyone saw was actually a
weather phenomenon and then everyone's
like that's a lie and this poor guy he's
like sitting in his office he's crying
it's like actually is a weather
phenomenon who made that famous joke
being like you don't believe in any
conspiracies you think the government is
always honest that they're batting a
thousand like they think they're always
right like are you crazy like there's no
way logically you could even think that
they're always honest they're always you
know and it's just i mean you must be
crazy if you really think that but left
a lot of lefties do think that now which
is so crazy compared to like the 60s
version of the lefty right which was
anti-establishment question everything
don't trust the government don't trust
the letter a free speech no matter how
many years ago even 10 years ago yeah
that's true occupy wall street was like
obama and biden are liars yeah don't
trust the big banks don't trust big
pharma
luke
the the dnc in the rnc for the 2016
cycle
where was the bigger protest
um
at the democrats it was the democrats it
was like over a thousand people and they
were trying to jump the fence and they
were shaking the fence the rnc had
almost nobody well the bernie bros were
pretty pissed off that they were getting
railroaded by clinton isn't this
the perfect way to understand like the
space we're in you know so there was
this guy who did a review of youtube
channels he was like tracking who was
influencing who and then he called my
channel at the time not tim castrox
didn't exist he said exclusively
critical of left
and he said the same thing about dave
rubin and a few other people and i said
isn't it possible that we're just
centrists criticizing the more extreme
and so he changed it some people to like
center and he got rid of the category
but here's here's a really good example
of where we are in the 2016 dnc rnc
cycle nobody protested republicans there
was a small handful kind of
thousands of people descended on the dnc
and tried breaking down the barricades
and hopping in and getting into the dnc
that's like
there you go
people don't like the democratic party
people didn't care a whole lot about
trump for the most part now i guess they
kind of went nuts in the last cycle
though you know
well this is why everyone thinks it's so
crazy that biden won as many votes as he
did which i do think that you're right
with that trump was anti-elected but to
look around and be like all the people
on the streets in new york city saying
stuff like you know screw joe biden is
very telling those are just normal
people walking by a news reporter and
they're like man i think i think a lot
of people are having a rude wake-up call
i wonder how many people are going
through cognitive dissonance where it's
like they weren't politically active
right they voted for joe biden and now
everything the trump supporters said
would happen is happening and they have
to reconcile that some people don't want
to do it but a lot of moderate people
are like yo
i will take a ham sandwich over joe
biden at this point yes dude thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you